he is so busy I don't know how he would
have the time he's got watch what
happens live the Real Housewives
franchise a new book he's a close friend
of Kelly Ripa but he's got so much going
on that he ruled out sitting next to her
on live so we want to know who he thinks
should get the job well I think Anderson
Cooper would be great uh and you know i
suck dl hughley the other day I thought
he was really great and really smart and
the two of them had great chemistry the
thing about Kelly is that she makes
everybody look good she really does so
they need to have people back again and
again and again so that you can really
see and he is the king of reality TV and
calls himself the ball / cheerleader of
housewives so we had to get him to dish
on Teresa Giudice is return the scoop
I'll give you about the first episode is
the first episode is Teresa's return
from prison and it is I've seen it three
or four times and I wept every time when
you see these four girls jump in her
arms it's like nothing that I've seen a
new york housewife Bethenny Frankel is
having a health crisis what happens is
that Bethenny starts bleeding profusely
and then that begins her health journey
the host of Bravo's watch what happens
live is expanding his media empire in
addition to writing his own books he'll
be publishing other people's works this
fall superficial more adventures from
The Andy Cohen Diaries will do